I can't tell you how many ambulances
there were they just seemed to to go on
go on forever I was walking along the
side of the building and they're all
queued up on both sides of the road it
was the police who called for an
ambulance after they found Hannah's dad
lying on the floor of his home last week
he's diabetic and had a fall he'd been
there for almost two days
but when he arrived here at Peterborough
hospital he endured another 12 hours
waiting inside an ambulance to be
admitted and then a further 24 hours
waiting in a corridor they just had so
many people in only you walk in there
and you're climbing over people there
are people sitting there with drips on
in the corridor there was blood on the
floor injured people everywhere it was
just I couldn't actually believe what I
was seeing Peterborough Hospital told
Sky News they're doing all they can to
reduce waiting times in their emergency
department including redeploying more
staff
talks between the health secretary and
union leaders on Monday failed to find a
breakthrough the government is sticking
to pay review body recommendations a
process Union say they will no longer be
a part of what we need is the government
to listen and to get around the table
and and to start negotiating better peer
deals better terms and conditions for
all NHS staff not just our ambulance
colleagues the relationship between
union and government is even more tense
after a new bill was introduced to
enforce minimum service levels for the
public sector during strike action all
we're saying is that
is it there why is he against that Mr
Speaker there's not a minimum level of
service any day because they've broken
the NHS
strikes could not have come at a worse
time with the NHS under so much pressure
patients are already at risk with
lengthy delays to response times and
handovers according to the office for
National statistics we're recording some
of the highest excess deaths we've ever
seen in the last six months alone there
were 1300 deaths every week over and
above what you would normally find covid
accounts for some of these debts but
according to health leaders most are
being caused by the crisis in the NHS
ambulance workers say they're fighting
for better pay and to improve patient
care
but industrial action puts more pressure
on a buckling NHS and almost certainly
more patient harm Ash's Joshi Sky News
Central London